أريد أن أبدأ بمعركة
باكموت، لقد خاضت أوكرانيا
معركة هائلة وألحقت خسائر فادحة بالجانب
الروسي، لكن في الأيام الأخيرة
حققت القوات الروسية بعض
المكاسب الحاسمة هناك، لماذا قررتم عدم
الانسحاب من باكموت،
نحن نفهم
ما تريده روسيا  لتحقيق
روسيا تحتاج على الأقل إلى بعض النصر،
انتصار صغير حتى من خلال تدمير
كل شيء في بلاكبيرد، بمجرد قتل
كل مدني هناك،
يجب عليهم وضع هذا العلم الصغير فوق ذلك
لإظهار ذلك المجتمع
أنه ليس انتصارًا لهم، بل كما
تعلمون.  لدعم
تعبئة مجتمعهم
من أجل خلق هذه الفكرة القائلة بأن
هذا جيش قوي بالنسبة لنا، إنه
فرق كبير، وهذا أمر تكتيكي بالنسبة لنا، نحن
نفهم أنه بعد الحالة المزاجية السيئة،
يمكنهم الذهاب إلى أبعد من ذلك،
يمكنهم الذهاب
إلى مدن أخرى في أوكرانيا في
كما تعلم سيدي الرئيس، شكك بعض
القادة الأوكرانيين في
تمسكهم بالباكمود، حيث
تعاني قواتهم من
خسائر فادحة في الوقت الحالي وسط مخاوف من أن ذلك
قد يضر بقدرة أوكرانيا على شن
هجوم الربيع، ماذا تقول
لهؤلاء القادة؟
سمعت شيئًا كهذا من
أي من هؤلاء القادة كيف يمكنني أه
التعامل مع هذا يعني أن شخصًا ما لديه أه
آرائه الخاصة ولكن يبدو الأمر
مزيفًا وتم إنشاؤه في الاتحاد الروسي
الذي لدينا بأن قواتنا يجب أن تكون
منسحبة وعلينا ذلك  فكر في
شعبنا أولاً ولا ينبغي أن
يحاصر أحد هذا أمر
مهم جدًا لكن العسكريين يرون
بأنفسهم أنه علينا أن نبقى أقوياء
هناك على الرغم من أن الروس
أه دمروا المدينة بأكملها ودمروا أه
كل شيء هناك أه القوات كانت تساعد
الأطفال أه  المدنيون يغادرون المدينة
اليوم، كان الناس يغادرون،
وكنا نساعد الجميع